no hello YouTube we have been focusing
on dignity global dignity is a something
PACA human of Finland and general Bryant
of the US and myself has started what
we're doing is we're focusing on dignity
as a core value that we want to be we
want it to be a base so that we can
actually go out and make the right
decision so that we have dinged assented
leadership team descend decision making
and the idea is that it's possible to
actually increase other people's David a
type of dignity capital so that if you
actually lift other people if you
increase other people's dignity the
beauty of that is of course that then
also your own dignity is increased so
we've taken this idea and we've gone
into schools all around the world and
talking to kids about what dignity means
to them ask them to define dignity in
their own words and also ask him to tell
stories of dignity from their own lives
and come up with a suggestion for what
they would like to do the next year
during freestyle people's dignity so I
was in Jordan while ago and in my plants
that the class I was assigned to there
was a girl and she told this story about
her teacher who was visually impaired
this was in her elementary school and
she was a very ambitious student so she
was a bit annoyed because this teacher
she wasn't able to use the blackboard
she wasn't able to catch a student they
were sending notes and so forth and she
thought she'd be better off with a
different teacher so she was a bit of
money she moved on to general high
school and she read in the paper that
this teacher was actually the first
visually impaired person in Jordan to
gain a PhD and her whole perspective
changed she now became proud that this
had been her teacher the teacher success
became her success and I thought that
was just a beaut
full story about how first of all this
more than meets the eye to every single
one of us every person has dignity and
secondly that there's so much more you
learn in the educational system than
just maths and the curriculum there's
something else that's about values about
who we are as human beings that is
really core an essential in creating the
world we want to achieve